In the first place,
you're the strongest primate in the world, you're the two most powerful primates, aren't you?
But
me,
he was certainly a formidable foe Ah,
I only fought him once in a
TV project
[Music]
You're no longer 50.
I fought a lion before.
Well, I'm fine, and I'm okay Everyone has four parts games. It's a funny face festival.
It
was just as fun as
[music] [music]
Hmmm ah ah ah ah yeah yeah yeah that talk mushroom I lost weight at that time Bennyting is just a thing that sees airspace and hallucinations So
send me a mushroom that looks just like that and grow into a giant  It's Super Mario-sama, but
my power doesn't change even 1mm Do
you understand why?
[music]
nume
About me You
brought me a
crusher The sound is also great, this time I'll protect
you  Nieh
ana
[music]